Galor c'est le désert du mois d'oût tout
le monde est en vacances même à la
télévision française qui a l'air de
marcher miraculeusement toute seule et
ici nous sommes dans le studio des
spicrines apparemment vide lui aussi
mais où un tableau de service très
éloquent vous allez voir à quasiment
valeur de témoignage du 13 au 23 août
Anne-Marie Pesson et toute seule toute
seule au tableau de service c'est
pourquoi nous avons voulu vivre avec
elle l'une de ces journées de travail
solitaire La
[Musique]
Baule
biarit ah ça c'est à jaccio les
LEC Nice oh les veenards Anne-Marie sont
téléspectateurs qui vous écrivent des
cartes postales de vacances oui c'est un
peu dur quand même c'est gentil mais
cruel au fond non c'est très gentil
pendant ce mois d'ù vous ne vous ennuyez
pas trop toute seule non non non non non
je dors et je vais chez le coiffeur tous
les jours mais alors à quoi occupez-vous
quand même les quelques rares loisirs
que vous avez
oh j'ai quelque chose là qui est assez
ça fait pas ça fait un peu vieille fille
mais dans le fond ben écoutez on ne vous
imagine absolument pas faisant de la
broderies c'est de la tapisserie ah
pardon de la tapisserie de la tapisserie
voyons c'est mignon ah oui c'est très
très mignon félicitations nêtes même pas
trop la nostalgie du pleinir de la mer
des petits oiseaux si j'y penserai
pendant mes vacances c'est quand vos
vacances en octobre en octobre d'ici là
on a le temps d'y penser alors écoutez
moi je vous propose quelque chose vous
allez nous raconter une de vos journées
et comme ça tous les téléspectateurs
vous tiendront compagnie pour une fois
d'accord d'accord
merci voilà je suis arrivée comme chaque
dimanche ce matin vers 9h30 au volant de
ma superbe 400
chevaux il n'y avait évidemment pas
grand monde dans les
rues j'ai facilement pu trouver une
place et il n'y avait pas grand monde
non plus dans les couloirs de la
télévision pas un chat à l'horizon sauf
les techniciens
heureusement un coup d'œil à la pendule
je suis à
l'heure
de toute façon je prends toujours le
temps de déjeuner plusieurs fois même si
possible ça m'est arrivé c'est
vrai et pour cela naturellement j'ai la
cantine grave problème le choix du
dessert et comme j'aime beaucoup les
gâteaux vous voyez que je suis
[Musique]
gâté
pas beaucoup de monde ici non plus et
tout de même c'est bien triste de manger
toute
seule
un incident technique on me rappelle
pour faire une
[Musique]
annonce je prends toujours le temps
aussi de m'aer un peu en faisant des mot
croisés la pause café quoi vous
[Musique]
connaissez il y a encore des Parisiens
qui ne sont pas en vacances et qui
viennent me tenir compagnie un petit
[Musique]
peu revenons au mot croisé un mot de C
lettres ah j'y suis repos vive les
vacances nous sommes venus rendre visite